the River Thames that flows through
London is one of the most well-known
waterways in the world for thousands of
years it has witnessed the city grow
along its banks and every day when the
tide goes out the riverbed offers up
some unique glimpses of the past
Holly Williams takes us for a trip along
the shore
on the banks of the River Thames
scavengers are hunting for Treasure not
for gold or anything of monetary value
very nice it's like a crown broken
shards of London's history oh we found
some pins
this is what londoners call mud locking
searching for coins pottery and other
ancient artifacts in the silt that's
exposed When the tide goes out
um like it's ancient and it could be
very old and cool because it's from a
long time ago
this is a taster session for first
timers I think that's a 10p actually can
you see like the Lions on it yes yeah
they'll need a permit from the London
Port Authority if they want to take it
up regularly that's nice
so that is Tudor um Christine Webb is
their guide there we go yeah lovely yes
very nice I'm gonna get to hold this yep
she's been mud liking for 11 years her
prize find this coin from 1572. on the
other side you've got the image of
Elizabeth first wow my aim I would love
although I don't know if it never
happened would be to get something that
I found in a museum on display
um ideally with my name next to it oh
look at this one mudlarks can't sell
Their fines but they say their hobby is
addictive and many have jaw-dropping
collections
350 years ago from Roman currency to
Medieval shoe buckles and stranger finds
they would also bake them into like a
pudding or a dessert at Christmas time
the Thames snakes its way through the
center of London for over 2 000 years
it's murky Waters have carried trading
boats warships and pleasure craft
the River Thames is the lifeblood of
this ancient city from Roman rule to
Viking raids from the Carnage of the
Black Death to Shakespeare's Globe
Theater all of it happened here
the ships were coming in from all across
the British Empire and there were times
where people said you could get from one
side of the river to the other just on
boats they were sort of so solidly
packed in on the river Dr Hannah
Stockton is a maritime historian who
told us the original mudlarks were
children driven by poverty in the 1700s
looking for scraps they could sell it
was the kind of thing you would only do
if you really really had to it was
really dirty dangerous work
these days mud locks are unashamed
history nerds people like Simon born
with a big following on social media
let's get some luck in the mug oh wow
look at that yeah he took usmad liking
to one of his favorite spots in East
London a former garbage dump all the
sewage was washed out from the streets
down down the pipes down the gutters and
ended up here it was basically used as a
rubbish pit so we're dealing with
hundreds maybe thousands of years of
sewage yeah essentially that yeah sewage
brilliant and rubbish that they didn't
want so this is a caudal cup Simons
discoveries include this cup from the
1600s an engraved tobacco tin from the
1700s that looks like Ordnance and in
artillery shell from World War II all of
it preserved because the mud in the
Thames has no oxygen which would
otherwise have destroyed them yeah
that's probably Victorian or thereabouts
and with the help of Simon's
well-trained eye where
is there we made our own find oh there
one penny from the reign of the current
King's grandfather there'll be a date on
it as well
1948
okay the first coin
that's pretty cool wow so there's one
penny it's easy to see how mud locks
catch the bug I would just love to be
put back in time for just a day to see
all the hustle and bustle all the
industry all the people the characters
that have obviously since gone but
they're still here in a way we can still
discover them just by finding the
objects they left behind I'm so excited
about your coins let's call it for CBS
Saturday morning Holly Williams London
you're welcome here's coin I yeah it's
hard
so awesome I know although I would have
to say I need gloves to go my block I
couldn't go don't mess with them yeah I
like the ordinance I mean that was a
significant piece of that yeah his
accent also I'm sorry it sounded so
Cockney to me I was thinking oh I wanted
a room somewhere I was thinking My Fair
Lady the whole time I did not even hear
it sorry I don't think it was it just
was in my head that way really cool
piece yeah fantastic